Student Academy Award winners tonight we
welcome you we welcome you to our
community and our family and we
celebrate the way our family is growing
with new voices new faces and new
perspectives we celebrate the fact that
inclusion just isn't the right thing to
do it is essential for the future of
film international markets are often the
key to box-office success of the film
and most of the world doesn't look or
sound like the people who filled the
seats at the first Academy Award
ceremony in 1929 or even the first
student Awards Academy a student Academy
Awards in 1973 this year we welcome
winners from as far away as China Israel
Switzerland Poland Norway Turkey and the
United Kingdom and we recognize that the
heart of moviemaking is all about
perspective whose perspective is being
represented
what do you see through the look through
the camera lens who is behind the camera
itself Student Academy Award winners we
are counting on you to widen the lens
even more your generation of
storytellers won't just be the film's
film industry's most diverse we look to
you to make this industry the best it
can be
I know I am looking out some of the
people who shape the future of film the
winners in the seven categories this
year alternative experimental domestic
animation documentary and narrative and
international document the documentary
you know I did this perfectly
I really did you know and all you guys
show up and I'm like international
narrative animation the document your
films showcase an incredible range of
talent and I can't wait to see what the
future holds for you all I also want to
say a word of thanks to my fellow
members of the Student Academy Awards
Executive Committee many of whom are in
the audience tonight I am so grateful
for the extra time you commit to this
program for many of us it is a passion
project so if everyone would please give
the members and
now it's time to meet our first
presenters to celebrate the winners in
the animation and international
animation categories we are joined by
two extraordinary artists they have
entertained movie fans of every
generation with their exceptional wit
and marvelous talent with both
live-action and animated films you know
them from the lego movies
21 Jump Street Cloudy with a Chance of
Meatballs and I'm gonna fangirl a little
bit right now spider-man into the spider
verse and you don't know them from their
one-week comedy punch up of The
Chronicles of Narnia voyage of the Dawn
Treader and I didn't know it either and
I worked on that digital campaign please
welcome the Academy Award winning duo
Phil Lord and Chris Miller
[Applause]
[Music]